foreign
[Music]
Al episode we talk about a much
anticipated sequel namely Joker 2 felia
do with the first movie Becoming the
most successful R-rated movie of all
time fans and critics are now eagerly
awaiting the sequel's release next year
now that shooting has started in
December it is just the right time to
talk about everything we know thus far
about the plot the cast and the
production in addition we pick up on the
hottest rumors for the sequel we also
include information about the previous
film so please be aware that there might
be spoilers for Joker one we hope you
enjoy our new original
Joker from 2019 is about the outsider
Arthur Flack who lives with his mother
and keeps himself above water with
occasional jobs in Gotham City after an
attack he receives a revolver from his
colleague Randall for self-defense and
his troubles become increasingly serious
eventually Arthur kills three men in a
Subway who harassed him due to his clown
outfit he later learns that mayoral
candidate Thomas Wayne is supposed to be
his biological father and to top it all
off his beloved mother suffers a stroke
from this point on things start going
downhill for Arthur in a TV show he also
gets called Joker for the first time
after having laughed out of control
constantly during a stand-up performance
events eventually come thick and fast as
Arthur confronts his supposed father
Thomas Wayne and realizes through a
stolen medical record from Arkham Asylum
that he was merely adopted by his
narcissistic mother he also comes to
understand that even his romantic
relationship with his neighbor was Pure
Imagination at the end of the movie
Arthur finally appears on a TV show made
up as a clown and shoots the host in
front of running cameras which in turn
leads to a riot in Gotham City during
this Riot Thomas Wayne and his wife are
seen being murdered in an alley by one
of the rioters the only one remaining is
their son Bruce Wayne in the end Arthur
is seen talking to a psychiatrist at
Arkham Asylum before fleeing from the
guards
after the short recap of the first part
now let's focus on Joker felia Dew
contrary to expectations the first film
made such massive waves that it was soon
clear a second part was to come besides
many theories which we will discuss next
there are two big Clues as to how the
plot will unfold first you can already
derive quite a lot from the officially
confirmed title phalia do is a
psychiatric term that translates as
Madness shared by two in simple terms it
concerns a person who suffers from
delusions these delusions can be
transmitted to a second healthy but
mentally unstable person if both
individuals are close once both people
are ill they may even reinforce each
other's delusions and make the entire
matter worse after that the disease can
only be treated if both individuals are
separated from each other if we now
apply this clinical picture to Joker
felia do the distribution of roles
quickly becomes clear Arthur is the one
who suffers from delusions and passes
them on to another person this other
person is none other than Dr harleen
quinzel Who works as a psychiatrist at
Arkham Asylum she has is probably better
known by her later name Harley Quinn
which she uses to instill Terror in
Gotham City however before that she
falls madly in love with Arthur Fleck
and thus forms a close bond with him the
first requirement for the transmission
of the mental disorder she also
eventually develops delusions and enters
into an extremely toxic relationship
with Arthur which is also largely in
keeping with the comic book original
this doesn't mean much in case of Doubt
since the first part stands entirely
alone and has hardly any connections to
the comic book original still the
current assumptions do Point towards a
clear Direction the second known clue
relates less to the actual story but
rather to the way the film will be made
the plot is to be told as a musical this
was first reported in June of last year
when The Hollywood Reporter exclusively
revealed the signing of Lady Gaga's
Harley Quinn and the film style it seems
surprising at first that they are not
sticking to the successful concept of
the first part and are instead trying a
completely new approach on second
thought however the idea makes sense as
it retains the uniqueness of the first
feature and creates a sequel that can
also hold its own in the end with Harley
Quinn as the second protagonist you also
get a different perspective on the
events there are even rumors the film
will be told mostly from her perspective
so making a musical out of the sequel is
not as far-fetched as one might think
especially since director Todd Phillips
and lead actress Lady Gaga have already
collaborated On A Star is Born and thus
are experienced in making musical films
we will now take a closer look at a few
theories that have been the subject of
heated discussion among fans and critics
for quite a while now one of the biggest
hopes of fans is that Bruce Wayne will
be introduced in more detail in the
second part and that they will probably
even hide Clues to his later life as
Batman since he is still a child in the
first part there would need to be a big
time Jump to show The Dark Knight in
action besides the Batman movie series
with Robert Pattinson which is also
separate coexists with Joker which is
why the idea of a Batman and jokerfully
a do would not quite fit other people
think that the title felia do is not so
much a reference to Harley Quinn but
that Arthur will have a son and pass on
his mental disorder to him Harley Quinn
would still play A Part after all it is
her who gives birth to the Joker's Child
although this Theory sounds very absurd
at first it actually originates from the
comic old lady Harley and Joker Jr would
later like to become just like his
father the third Theory fits in well
with the fact so far which is why it is
considered one of the more realistic
ones as we can clearly see at the end of
the first film The Joker gathered some
followers around him and it could thus
be that one of these followers is trying
to emulate their Idol a little too much
as the film progresses we would then
have two jokers competing with each
other perhaps the clash between the two
will even result in Arthur's defeat
which in turn could give way to a
younger Joker more of a wish than a
theory is the adaptation of a storyline
from Batman the Animated Series in the
episode mad love you can see how the
Joker breaks out of the Arkham Asylum
with the help of Harley and then tries
to kill Commissioner Gordon this episode
of the animated series is very popular
which is why many fans would love to see
a similar storyline for jokerfelia do as
well however there are no concrete
indications of this
as for the cast some information is
already available in addition to the
obvious return of Joaquin Phoenix as the
Joker and Lady Gaga's Harley Quinn
Arthur's neighbor Sophie will also make
another appearance the single mother
will again be played by 31 year old
zaisy beats and needless to say we can't
wait to find out how big her part is
going to be in the upcoming film some
other well-known actors have also joined
the cast including Harry Potter actor
Brendan Gleason The Maze Runner actor
Jacob Laughlin get out actress Catherine
Keener and Harry Lottie who can
currently be spotted alongside Christian
Bale in the Netflix film The Pale Blue
Eye sadly it is not known yet which
roles the actors are going to play so
patience is still needed in this regard
even before the theatrical release of
Joker in October 2019 director Todd
Phillips talked about how he would
gladly work on a sequel should it be a
success however he later also pointed
out that the film was originally
intended to be a completely Standalone
film without the need for a sequel well
just a month later The Hollywood
Reporter claimed that a sequel was in
the works causing disagreements in the
industry as deadline in turn asserted
that their sources had affirmed that
negotiations for a sequel had not yet
begun much uncertainty eventually
followed and the pandemic that caused
delays in the movie business all over
the world also added to it causing
things to go quiet around Joker 2 for a
while then in the summer of 2022 It All
Happened fairly quickly director Todd
Phillips officially announced the sequel
stating he and colleague Scott silver
had written the script and that the
title would be falia do with an
Instagram post Phillips finally
confirmed the start of filming on
December 10th the post features what is
believed to be a scene from the film
showing Arthur Fleck having a shave we
are already excited about the first
trailer and look forward to the
theatrical release on October 4th 2024
and there you go that was our original
for Joker felia do are you looking
forward to the film and what are your
thoughts on it being made as a musical
also what are your expectations for the
plot feel free to leave a comment below
[Music]